a woman from Yemen who wants to fly to
California to visit her dying child as
being denied entry to the US because of
a controversial travel ban two-year-old
Abdullah Hassan a US citizen is on life
support
I had Children's Hospital in Oakland his
mother is barred from flying to the US
by President Trump so-called Muslim ban
and is stuck more than 7,500 miles away
in Egypt Matea via al spoke with the
boy's father a US citizen who is begging
the Trump administration to let his
family reunite one last time I'm
literally seeing my son dying in front
of my eyes Ali Hassan son Abdullah has a
degenerative brain disease and has been
on life support
for over a month suffering from seizures
and unable to open his eyes or breathe
on his own it's been about five weeks
since Abdullah smiled at his father so
hard from every day that that that day
who are you tell me you were just
hugging him so hard and you were just
literally came in smiling that's that
that's the last thing I seen from him
why have you chosen to keep him on life
support to have a chance for his mother
to come see him
posada met his wife Seamus whele in
war-torn Yemen after giving birth
suela fed to Egypt with Abdullah as
their sons health deteriorated Hassan a
US citizen decided to take Abdullah also
a US citizen two doctors in California
but he had to leave his wife behind as a
Yemeni citizen she can't enter the u.s.
under the trump administration's travel
ban targeting several muslim-majority
nations the president says that this ban
was necessary to keep our country safe
do you believe that's what's happening
you know I mean anyone that come to the
u.s. then they're gonna come and just do
anything bad you know they come over
family
Hasan backed by a coalition of faith and
community groups he's asking for a
temporary humanitarian parole visa for
his wife to enter the country it is
immoral for us to just stand by and
watch as this mother mourn so far away
alone for CBS this morning media vol
Sacramento well this story is not over
the State Department says consular
offices can grant waivers on a
case-by-case basis it could depend on
whether granting one is in the national
interest the applicant doesn't pose a
security threat and denying it would
cause undue hardship